افتتح رئيس الوزراء الهندي ناريندرا مودي معبد
رام الجديد الذي تبلغ تكلفته عدة ملايين من الدولارات في مدينة إيودا اليوم، ويفي
بناء المعبد
بوعده الطويل الأمد في
عام الانتخابات، حيث يقع المعبد الهندوسي المثير للجدل
في موقع مسجد يعود تاريخه إلى القرن السادس عشر دمره
الهندوس.
القوميون في
عام 1992 أثاروا أعمال شغب أدت إلى مقتل حوالي
2000 شخص عبر S ينضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة
من ioda لذا عبر ما هو الأحدث على
هذا
R أنا أقف على بعد حوالي 2.5 كم من
المكان الذي تم فيه تكريس تمثال الكبش
بين الساعة 1220 والساعة 12:30 ظهرًا.  بالتوقيت المحلي
للهند الآن، هذه لحظة تاريخية، إنها
لحظة مثيرة للجدل أيضًا
وسأخبرك لماذا أه لنبدأ باللحظة
التاريخية، إنها لحظة تاريخية
للهندوس في جميع أنحاء الهند والعالم
لأن هذه هي اللحظة التي كانوا
ينتظرونها  لأنه تتويج للدفعة التي قامت
بها المنظمات القومية الهندوسية
على مدى العقود الأربعة الماضية لبناء معبد
الكبش في الموقع الذي
يعتقدون أنه مسقط رأس اللورد رام،
ولكن بالنسبة للمسلمين الذين تحدثنا إليهم هنا
في AIA، فإن هذا يعيد فتح كل الجراح
لأن  هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين فقدوا
أفراد عائلاتهم في
الحقوق المجتمعية لعام 1992 التي تحدثت عنها حيث
مات 2000 شخص بعد أن كان الكثير منهم من
أفراد عائلات المسلمين الذين
يعيشون هنا، يشعرون وكأنهم مواطنون من الدرجة الثانية،
هذا ما يجب أن يقولوه أكثر
من أي شيء آخر.  قال الأشخاص الذين تحدثنا إليهم إننا
سنشاهد الحفل من مسافة بعيدة
الآن، وهذا أمر مهم بالنسبة لرجل واحد كنت
ستراه في الإطار في
الحرم الداخلي لمعبد الكبش، أنا
أتحدث عن زعيم الهند
رئيس الوزراء الهندي ناريندرا مودي إنه
عام انتخابي وناريندرا مودي
يسعى لولاية ثالثة قياسية كزعيم
أه الهند كرئيس للوزراء ويأتي هذا
الافتتاح قبل أشهر فقط من
الانتخابات ما
يقوله أعضاء حزب المعارضة هو أنه قام
بتسييس هذا الأمر على طول  مع حزبه،
حزب باريا جان، يعتقدون أنه
يستخدم هذا كفرصة قبل
الانتخابات للاستفادة من المزيد من
الأصوات لتعزيز قاعدة التصويت الهندوسية
أه التي لديهم حاليًا أيضًا
حصة كبيرة من الأصوات وهذا هو الوضع
الآن، دعنا  الحديث عن الاحتفالات
وكذلك بمجرد
حدوث التكريس روزماري كانت هناك مروحيات
حلقت فوق أه المعبد وكذلك
هذه المنطقة، أنا في الواقع أحمل إحدى
بتلات الورد التي سقطت علينا هنا
والتي أه كانت جزءًا من  المروحية
التي ألقت بتلات مشوية كجزء من
الاحتفال، ليست الهند وحدها هي
التي تحتفل بهذا، بل الهنود في
الخارج أيضًا، وقد احتفل تايمز سكوير نيويورك
أيضًا بهذه اللحظة في الفترة التي
سبقت التكريس، حيث كان هناك
عشرات من الهنود في تايمز سكوير
يحتفلون بهذا اليوم.  لحظة لدينا صور
توضح كيف تم ذلك أه الليلة الماضية، لذا
في الختام، هذه هي اللحظة التي
كان رئيس الوزراء ينتظرها، لقد كان
وعدًا أوفي به ولكن هناك
أقلية من مجتمع المسلمين الذين
يشاهدون هذا متوترين بعض الشيء وحزينين وما شابه
قلت إنها أعادت فتح جراحهم
من الماضي من عام 1992 إليك